[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome back to your continued coverage
of the world's most densely packed
keynote wwdc 2019 and i'm going to say
that loki my favorite announcement from
that entire keynote
was ipad os 13. you see if you remember
there were a lot of complaints and
feelings in my ipad pro review and many
others about how this is clearly the
best ipad ever it's incredible hardware
great screen
great battery great chip
but it's still sort of held back by the
software by ios and it still felt like
just an ipad well fast forward a couple
weeks till now till that crazy keynote
happened and now we have an update
alongside ios 13 specifically for the
ipads it's ipad os now it's not an
entirely new operating system it's still
ios 13 for ipad but this ipad os
directly addresses so many of the
complaints and those features that it
was lacking that sort of bring it up to
speed of a much more impressive computer
so in a way
this software update kind of feels like
it saves the ipad pro for me so let's
break this down first of all the widgets
on your home screen so i never thought i
would say that about ios but technically
you do have these here so at least on
the left hand side in a vertically
scrolling list but these are the ones
that were over to the side of your home
screen on your iphone but you can pin
them right alongside the rest of your
smaller icons and they go a long way
towards making it feel a bit more like a
real computer already you know and i
actually think a lot of possibilities
open up with the widgets that you can
put over there they're always available
there's a lot of glanceable information
and a lot of one-touch functions if you
have some important apps up there so i'm
a big fan of that and then there is the
multitasking improvements so again a lot
of this is learning gestures and things
like that there's sort of a learning
curve to them but you can have apps side
by side like you always have but now you
can have two instances of the same app
side by side next to each other so notes
next to notes or safari next to safari
it's one of those things i didn't know i
would like but turns out to be pretty
useful
and then of course there's also the
slide over apps and the whole gesture
system that goes with that so there's
multitasking between slide over windows
and quick switching between them and all
the stuff stays in memory and it's
always remembered so if you have
multiple apps and spaces next to each
other you can switch between those pairs
of apps it's pretty impressive so i feel
like this is one of those features that
you could not use at all to start but
slowly start introducing them into your
workflow until you get really good at
them and then they feel irreplaceable
and then okay remember when i said in
the original ipad review having a usb c
port makes the workflow dream seem like
you know just plug your camera directly
into that port or plug a card reader
straight in
import and then start editing your
photos or whatever you're doing
you couldn't do that on the ipad and it
was a bummer that that wasn't supported
until now in ipad os 13 you now can plug
in a flash drive or plug memory in
directly into the ipad and import into
your apps and start working this
obviously feels like one of the features
they should have had from the beginning
but now that it's here thank you
finally that's originally what i was
expecting when i saw usbc on the ipad
pro so now let's take advantage of that
there's also this column view and the
files app that's starting to behave a
lot more like finder with the ability to
quickly copy and paste files and
compress files and folders into zip
files i feel like also a lot of signing
documents will be a lot easier now that
you can do this so file management is
much better and then also desktop class
browsing so that was another one of my
big complaints about the ipad was the
inability to use several important
desktop sites because they all treated
safari on the ipad like safari on the
iphone just like another mobile browser
so i was pretty impressed and happy to
see full desktop class browsing now so
first thing i had to try was google
drive that all now fully works it's not
perfectly smooth but it works which is
great and then desktop youtube and the
creator studio also works so things like
adding end cards and updating
descriptions and a lot of the stuff i
would do on the desktop it now all works
perfectly in the web browser this is
literally one of the things i would
carry around a macbook pro to be able to
do because i don't trust doing that
stuff on my phone there's also now a
download manager in safari so you can
use it for sites like dropbox and
box.com and google drive for natively
downloading files that's awesome for me
because the ultimate team i play for in
new york empire we put game footage all
in the shared folder in google drive but
i couldn't download from google drive to
the ipad to watch it offline i could
only stream so now i can just straight
up download it to the ipad and just
watch it like a normal file
it's great and then there's a bunch of
other little improvements so things like
the keyboard anytime you're typing
anything you can pinch it down and it
becomes this iphone size keyboard and
you can move it anywhere you want and
then type with one hand or do swipe
typing it's not the prettiest thing in
the world but the fact that you can do
that in one quick gesture is pretty nice
and also if you use the apple pencil for
markup a lot another feature that's
super useful is you can now use the
pencil to take a screenshot by swiping
up from the corner then you immediately
are in markup mode and you can start
drawing on whatever screenshot you just
took that is clean and then the icing on
the cake is another new feature called
sidecar so if you have a mac
and an ipad as the name suggests it'll
let you use the ipad as a second display
for the mac so i saw this demo at wwdc
it was literally two clicks away in the
display settings and then suddenly this
macbook pro has a second display that's
apple pencil compatible and with the
super low latency of the pencil you can
just start drawing and editing i imagine
this to be useful for artists and people
that do a lot of photoshop work and
things with the stylus
i don't know about replacing those wacom
tablets that are so specialized that a
lot of workflows use right now but as
responsive as this is and as good as it
looked in beta this looked really
promising oh and let me just say that
the improved latency of the stylus they
said on stage that it went from 20
milliseconds to 9 milliseconds i didn't
know if i would notice that but trying
it it is incredibly fast now it looks
and feels like you're actually writing
directly onto the ipad's screen i don't
know if they could even make the latency
any shorter than this and if i would
notice it at all it is super fast so
does all this stuff take the ipad pro
from being just another ipad to being
a sort of a computer replacement for
more people
as you might imagine the answer depends
on what you do on your computer but for
me if i'm not video editing on my laptop
the answer is actually
yes
pretty much everything i do in between
desktops as far as mobile work
i can now actually do
on the ipad pro and that mobile web
browser being treated like a desktop
class web browser is a major part of
that i also really like the widgets on
the more compact home screen and the
multitasking improvements and all this
stuff to me legitimately saves the ipad
so today
like i said since i don't edit videos on
the go anymore i do it in between at
desktops
today i'm taking my laptop
out of my backpack and i'm gonna be just
carrying ipad pro
we'll see how long this lasts but i
really feel like i can do everything i
used to do i don't know whether to be
mad at apple for like holding these
features back and then finally
delivering them later to blow all our
minds or if i should be super happy for
apple for listening to our feedback and
actually updating the ipad with all
these features for what we asked but
what i do know is the improvements that
they've made to ipad os are stellar i
think when they do hit the ipad in their
final form because this is still early
beta and it'll be a public beta soon but
when these finally start hitting
people's ipad pros they're going to
notice they're going to be major
improvements
i think i'll really like them i really
like it
either way
that's been it thanks for watching this
video
catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]
you